Okay. Let's move on and now we're going to
talk about HTTP. If you recall, this was what
we described as the main protocol of the
Web. This is what your browser uses to talk
to the, to Web servers. HTTP stands for
HyperText Transfer Protocol. The request from your browser for
the URL www.example.com/foo, begins with a request line, it'll
look something like this. This is the request line,
now HTTP is a, a very simple text
protocol. So, this text is sent over the Internet
to the server, just like this, it's human readable
too. The request line has three main parts. First
there's the method, next is the path and finally
is the version. The method is what type of
requests are making to the server. The most common
method by far is GET. And this is how
you GET a document from the server. Other popular
methods are GET and POST. There are other ones, but
these are the ones we're going to use in the
class. Next is the path. In this case, it's /foo.
You remember this from the URL. But the path
and URL comes here. This is the actual document we're
requesting from the server. And finally is the version. It's
always http/ and then a version number. Most browsers and
servers these days speak at 1.1, but we'll also
touch on 1.0 a little bit in this class. Because
1.0 has, you know, a few uses of its
own. Now, you're wondering where the host name is in
this request line? It's not here. All that's here
is the path. We're connected to this host, your browser
connected to this host. Or, if we're playing around
with HTTP, we made the connection. But that's how we
know where we are. So that's, this is used for making
the connection, and the path is used for making the request.
Let's have a quick quiz.
Given the following URL, example.com/foo/logo.png?P=1#tricky, what
is the request line to get this URL using HTTP 1.1?